what up what up what up hello everybody
happy Friday super excited gratitude
journal live stream we're here number 25
it's a beautiful day here in Toronto the
Blue Jays a plane so super excited and
we're doing this again and I'm pumped to
see you guys welcome it's great to see
you happy Friday we do this every week
day we share three things that were
great before I share mine you guys share
yours in the live chat and it's
important that you make it consistent
with you do with me every day or you do
it just on your own consistency is
important and that you actually feel
what you're grateful for ask yourself
the why if you want to have the benefits
of gratitude then you need to ask
yourself that question really feel on an
emotional level it's not going to stop
going to work and we need to happier
healthier more well aligned
entrepreneurs to go out and make this
world a better place and that's you guys
and I'm grateful to be spending some
time with you here today so I'm going to
start off and then we'll get to you guys
in a live chat for me I'm going to start
off with the with Mark Draeger so i had
i have my master my group meeting last
night and in marks one of the members
and we're giving advice to another
member that was pretty solid advice and
I'm ready to move on to the next person
because I kind of I hosted and say you
know okay we're done with you or go to
the next person I was all set to move on
to the next person and Mark said he's
not gonna follow that advice he's not
gonna do it and it was true you know I
was kind of thinking it too but mark
called it out and then it led to a
deeper conversation as to why he's not
going to do it and so I appreciate the
love it's all out of love for this other
member right I appreciate I appreciate
the love Draeger had there and you know
being willing to to call it out in front
of everybody you know showing
love and so yeah I respect that I
respect that and I didn't do what I was
thinking about it but I didn't do it so
I like that Mark pointed it out so that
we could um number 2 i'm going to go
with my belief playlist i have a music
playlist i listened to every morning
called the belief playlist its public
you guys can check it out if you want
and it's just music that gets me going
gets me excited gets me moving and i
woke up today didn't have a lot of sleep
last night and i just put on the list
and start start feeling it already it's
the fastest way to change your state and
so i highly recommend having you you
guys have a playlist that you can put on
in the morning or whenever you need you
know sometimes I've been doing this
experiment before going on to my videos
when I when I shoot from the Toronto
dance salsa for the week in my ears I'll
have a song something that I'm excited
by while I'm thinking about my answer
and then get on get on camera and I like
it it's working and so you know
incorporate music more into your daily
routine and pick songs that make you [ __ ]
a lot I'm super good for my list and
number 3 i'm grateful for i'm grateful
for my hustle in doing this I you know I
was talking last night at my meeting
about the number of videos that I'm
doing and you know I produce more
content than a lot of people and it's
why I love for you guys right like this
stream warning I do this anyway right i
do this anyway with my team i doing this
here with you because i want i want you
to feel the benefits of it as well so it
doesn't take any extra time out of my
day to do it and one of the reasons why
so one of us might do all these videos
is for you but also for me you know for
me to get better for me to practice for
me to improve my skills and if you want
to get better at something you have to
you have to be prolific at it you gotta
grind in
hustle and get better and you know the
quantity leads to the quality and I feel
like I'm getting better feel like
everybody video I'm getting better ready
to go make an even bigger mark and I'm
really I'm grateful for that I'm really
grateful for that so those are my three
things for you guys leaving the live
chat for those of you watching
afterwards leave it down the comments
below don't just watch and be a lurker
you know leave comments because if you
write it down words make it real right
Jen if you write it down you're much
more likely to feel it so put it in
there let's uh let's get to the comments
here we got we have five minutes before
i head over to the twitch stream
millville don't forget the clapping evan
the clapping has become it's become the
ritual I like a video doesn't count
without the clapping Wow Jay rises
calling it the clap millville is calling
it the thunderclap hashtag the clap
hashtag on the club now hey well what do
you guys want to call it what do we call
him it Jay rises is calling up will you
read yours come over here read your
thing why don't you write here Jay rises
going before what I don't you want it
right there you're going say from memory
anyways but I'm thankful for the lights
that illuminate so easily and
effortlessly I'm thankful for fast food
which makes my life so convenient and
I'm thankful for the growth of the
eSports industry it's rising I like it
what do we got ruching the house too
happy friday kappa hello Sarah hey Bob
good morning good morning Sarah buenos
dias a todos que el bien I love it when
we got or viv Oh mark draeger's in the
chat mark there you go you got called
out number one thing in before today mr.
Draeger coach Billy Cooper people for
you doing this Evan much love bro Zeno
I'm grateful for 4G when Wi-Fi bails on
me kind of important
I know I don't have 4G you know my bday
define the white winters I've
experienced when I was young I think
they're mostly thing of the past and and
once again the positivity and
encouragement of alienation I love it
thank you say no mark Draeger in the
chat being thanked respect we got claps
happen and keep it real Markieff remark
or getting a lot of a lot of Mark love
happening here much showing love kale
beyond big before number one waking up
to another beautiful day number two for
the wind for providing cool circulating
air throughout the city I love it I love
it number three for all the people who
donated to my go fund me awesome que el
bien mark respect mark where are you
what are you grateful for mark come on
give us three things what else suemez
sir can you explain the technique of
gratitude which is explaining a magic
book I haven't read the magic book so I
don't know Alex good morning everyone
welcome good morning good morning good
morning kale bienes has to go to Orlando
okay awesome congratulations Darth Vader
Anakin lets his dream Moscow what was it
Oh his dream is to go to Orlando I love
it Rishi I'm incredibly grateful for
people who make me laugh very cool I
love it too Anthony I'm giving for trees
they give me oxygen pages to write and
read from and view as a dance when they
win the blows Louise here too I did see
you guys are heading me in the check
rsday hey everyone welcome sherry good
morning grateful for down feather bed
pillows natural gas to provide heat to
any electricity goes out I love a man 11
raekwon I'm grateful to be confident and
be myself in a society that wants you to
conform to negativity amen much grateful
for flashlights and batteries and
candles and firelight which we might
need to use here in the pack
in w I don't know what that means but
stay safe Jen Sarah people got to meet
Ryan Holliday and learn from him and his
talk yesterday in NYC Brian's awesome
way to the top 10 I went to go see him
in New York we did a video together hung
out a little bit he's pretty cool what
part of team yeah he's helping with
marketing the book to reaches people for
my for her brother hi mayo that parent
said okay we help each other laugh so
much i love is a laughing theme here
chimayo chimayo or high Mayo well you
know probably cleared up on the twitch
stream later on okay we gotta we gotta
run off to the twitch stream mark did
you say what you're grateful for mark
mark come on what's drinker grateful for
it I'm doing a search Draeger how do i
search the comments Draeger all right
what are you grateful for I don't see
what Marcus gate before mark man I gave
you a lot of love today bro equal to
show up it's all good all right guys we
gotta head over to twitch we're going to
play some legal engines and some
business questions if this is the last
time I see you though today have an
awesome close to the week show your
gratitude continue to believe or
whatever your one word is I'll see you
soon